Es ist die größte Automobilfabrik der Welt:
Volkswagen in Wolfsburg.
Dieselaffäre, Betrügereien und jetzt
Tierversuche – die Skandale um den
Konzern reißen nicht ab.
Jedes Mal heißt es, das wird
Konsequenzen haben.
Doch das Gegenteil ist der Fall.
VW hat eines der erfolgreichsten
Geschäftsjahre
seiner Firmengeschichte hinter sich.
Über zehn Millionen VW-Fahrzeuge
wurden im vergangenen Jahr
weltweit ausgeliefert –
ein Plus von rund vier Prozent.
Doch wie kommt das?
Was macht die Marke VW so stark,
dass die Autokäufer ihr trotz
allem weiter vertrauen?
Antworten darauf haben die
Profis in den Markenagenturen,
wie hier in Berlin bei Metadesign.
Volkswagen ist einer ihrer Kunden,
genauso wie Porsche, Eon oder Siemens.
Starke Marken, denen Skandale
offensichtlich nur wenig anhaben können.
Es ist eine Marke, die … denen [der]
die Menschen vertrauen.
Und warum vertrauen sie ihr?
Weil sie mit ihr aufgewachsen sind,
weil sie ein Teil ihrer Sozialisation
gewesen ist.
Weil sie vielleicht sogar ein Teil ihres
eigenen Aufstiegs war.
Und die Marke war immer im Kern
ein Teil der inneren Gesellschaft,
des Kerns der Gesellschaft.
Die Menschen haben über die Jahrzehnte
hinweg ein unfassbares Vertrauen
in diese Marke aufgebaut.
Also, das Depot, was aufgebaut
worden ist, ist riesig groß.
Natürlich ist Volkswagen nicht
ganz unbeschadet geblieben.
In den USA musste der Autobauer bis
jetzt 25 Milliarden Euro Strafe zahlen.
Und auch wenn der Absatz insgesamt steigt,
in Europa gerät VW bei den
Dieselfahrzeugen unter Druck.
Hier ist der Dieselanteil im Jahr 2017
um mehr als 8 Prozent in Spanien gesunken,
in Deutschland um rund sieben Prozent.
Wir haben das mal als „tainted love“,
also enttäuschte Liebe bezeichnet.
Und genauso ist das Verhältnis zwischen
Volkswagen und …
Das ist wieder kittbar,
das kann man wieder richten,
aber es bleibt erst mal ein Misstrauen,
und dieses Misstrauen ist sehr tief.
Volkswagen muss versuchen,
da jetzt gegenzusteuern.
Metadesign hat im Auftrag von VW
eine Kampagne entworfen,
die den Autobauer als digitalen
Dienstleister in Szene setzen soll.
Autos, die per App mit Smartphone oder
Tablets vernetzt sind –
so soll die Zukunft aussehen.
Zugute kommt den Unternehmen:
Konsumenten sind vergesslich.
Oft sind die Affären nur
ein Sturm im Wasserglas
und haben keine langfristigen Folgen.
Beim Autokauf spielt das Umwelt-
bewusstsein ohnehin kaum eine Rolle.
Laut Umfragen des deutschen
Automobilclubs ADAC
steht auf Platz eins die Zuverlässigkeit,
auf Platz zwei Sicherheit,
gefolgt vom Raumangebot,
dem Design und der Marke.
Das Umweltbewusstsein kommt erst
weit hinten auf Platz 24.
Auch diese Berliner Agentur ist auf
strategische Markenkommunikation
spezialisiert.
Zu ihren Kunden zählt [zählen]
unter anderem
die Deutsche Bank und die Telekom.
Deutsche Konsumenten sind
Marken besonders treu.
In einer Studie wurden sie 2017 befragt,
welchen Marken einer Branche
sie am meisten vertrauen.
Bei den Automobilen war es –
Volkswagen.
Auch Marken wie Nestlé gelten
als vertrauenswürdig,
obwohl der Konzern in diverse
Lebensmittelskandale verwickelt war.
Oder die Textilkette C&A,
die in Billiglohnländern nähen lässt.
Marken halten dann Skandale aus,
wenn sie sich ihnen auch stellen,
und das nachvollziehbar
und transparent.
Und wenn sie dann aus dieser
Analyse des …
der Krisensituation heraus
glaubwürdig aufzeigen,
dass sie ähnliche Effekte in der
Zukunft vermeiden wollen.
Markenvertrauen kann
erschüttert werden,
es darf nur nicht mehrfach
erschüttert werden.
Das ist der wesentliche Punkt.
Aus der Dieselaffäre scheint VW noch
einmal davongekommen zu sein.
Doch hat der Konzern mit seinen
Abgastests an Tieren
und laut Zeitungsberichten sogar Menschen
eine neue Schwelle überschritten?